well I guess they don't have the big
Hollywood marketing budgets and Comedy
Central so they got me shilling out here
on a street corner I don't think you
should do it I know you know what a bad
idea is you're in a lot of movies that
are bad ideas but this is a worse idea
this is like die hard or live free
whatever that was a bad idea this is a
worse idea this is your the biggest
movie star in the world they should be
well you're almost the biggest at one
point you were almost the biggest movie
star in the world and they should be
treating you better than this
Comedy Central trying to save a few
bucks is oh you're right you're
right
does anybody watch Comedy Central
anymore be there man I'm your
roastmaster okay gotta go bye
you
[Music]